I'm going to die let it happen while
there's still some we left
if Sansa did have to die how would you
want her to go something that really
like drags out every full episode the
only thing I can think of is poisoning
that's the long one or just like a slow
stabbing I don't know it's just
something that lasts a long time so I
can milk it he poisoned my son your king
take maybe perhaps dying an aria sword
would be a good way what do we say to
the god of death but today I think you
would have to top the lot like in years
to come I hope there's like a show where
it's like the top best deaths on Game of
Thrones so we would have to be number
one so far for me number one death is
the melting goals on Viserys his face
which was early on and so I think you'd
have to be something along those lines
something maybe like glass melting on
her face and then like over all of her
face and you still be able to see her
frozen dead expression he was no dragon
fire cannot kill the dragon
so this is something I've thought about
and I think it would be really funny if
she just like got really close to the
Iron Throne and then exploded I think
that would be hilarious
that'll be good I can hear the cries of
millions of fans everywhere right Valar
morghulis yes all men must die
which we are not too many
I'd want something really gruesome but
it's really hard to top the producers
they can't with the most creative deaths
I know I'd like intestines ripped out
and used to be strangled with it the
Lannisters send their regards
she'll be the end of you possibly it's a
good question just some of old age are
you going to order him to kill me I'm
the only one you have left my children
are gone my father is gone it's just me
and you now this one more yet to come
gives the order